I got to tell you my nightmare same
thing so I get a call alright so I'm on
that TV alright already so Fox Gold
calls me and they say there's another
sitcom that we really want you on but
the showrunners don't want you on it
like well then I don't want to [ __ ]
do it yeah he's a gal but we think that
you're the right guy and who are these
people talking saying that we think
you're the right guy the network okay
you know so you know you you you you
don't say no I show up and it's the the
pilots called new car smell right and
the star was Brooke Shields okay who
else was on it Dave Attell a love Dave
without Dave Attell and Jimmy Schubert
that was there I wasn't gonna make it
through because this is what happened I
show up and the first thing the
showrunner say is like we want to get e1
na B which is long Duk dong from 16 can
they literally said yes they so they
don't want they don't want me and I go
so I would do I did a rehearsal and then
the director was great the director he
was another guy that saved me was David
Schwimmer he's on a show friends Oh
David Schwimmer some friends Rick Ross
and dinner Ross was like I just you know
the show nerds they don't but you know
we're trying to work with it so you know
just hang in there a day would go by and
half my lines would be caught and they
would be like David Schwimmer every
every day it would be like yeah I just
they're just cutting your scenes down to
but just hang in there you're you know I
think you're doing fine hang in there
by the end of the week I have one line
and the showrunners I'm gonna just say
it go [ __ ] themselves the Cullen
brothers oh my god okay
what you first of all first of all
Guinea Watanabe or me Bobby Lee all day
all right
in my head you know that's what I'm
thinking all right secondly it's like I
know Rob Cullen right I used to hang out
with him with dice back in the day when
I used to open for dice he was
supposedly a friend right and then by
the end of the [ __ ] week I have one
[ __ ] line right and and Brooke
Shields would would not even look at me
yes I meet her at craft service and she
would just look through me and I would
get both I was getting boils on my face
it was the worst job I've ever gotten
that's worse than not getting a job or
than getting fired from a job that's
horrific yeah you're there you feel on
the wanted your lines are getting
dwindled down to a line when you had
bunch of lines and scenes and it got to
the point where no one's talking to you
and you still have to be there cold
shoulder oh my god it was the worst you
know and you know and you know to their
credit I guess at the time Gideon wound
ami was more of a name because I was
only on my second season or first season
of Mad no one knew who I was but I was
young and it's like if I'm there if
that's what I'm saying is is that when
an actor is there right work all that
[ __ ] out before we get there
right right all the uncomfortability and
the kinks and all that stuff said that
when we show up number one we know that
we're wanted there number two that we're
going to be used
we're not extras we went through the
process right and three just a little
bit of a diggity give us some dignity
and like you can't even do your best if
those are the conditions you're gonna
suck and you're gonna keep sucking and
it's like handle that [ __ ] before game
day because now it's game day and I'm
here to play and you
eyes are like you're not on the team
yeah yeah so how the [ __ ] am I supposed
to help anyone yeah it it hurts us yeah
we're burning we're getting hurt it's
number it's hard enough to even [ __ ]
do it and number two it's like we're
human beings we have feelings and we're
susceptible and we're supposedly were
artists we have like you know a lot of
times we we were just exposed nerves
right phoner ball and then they poked at
it but that's how that's how Hollywood
becomes very delusional because the
delusion becomes strategy it's like a
coping mechanism you know you when you
if you learn if you can learn delusion
if that's a learned thing yeah then you
can seriously make it in this industry
because you're exposed nerves aren't
being you know racked every day yeah
yeah it's learned like people are always
like my mom my dad they're like we don't
know how you do it you get told no every
single day yeah I'm like oh yeah I mean
I'm used to that and she goes out every
day I kept I was like oh you know who I
wanted I wasn't tall enough I wasn't
sure enough I wasn't good enough
okay cool what's next especially
sometimes when you go in and you're on
fire when you know when you I've
literally gone in auditions where I
walked away gone I would be shocked if I
don't get that yeah and then no call
nothing oh yeah didn't even know you
read I could read that you're getting
yeah no we never they never got it they
were in the room that's like right and
they're like oh like when you did that
I'm never gonna make it when he
auditioned for terminator and I
seriously like I like staged a vigil
like I lit like so many [ __ ] candles
yeah and you know I was like I don't
know you because you know you know when
you're just not with it and when you're
not doing it and when
you [ __ ] sucked yeah and I went in
and I was like okay I did well and then
there was just nothing not even no
feedback ever but I mean there have been
times where like I even get good
feedback from Network and then I scour
the internet for weeks to find out who
oh I don't do that at all because I
can't number one I don't do that and
number two I can't watch it oh the show
riah I don't know how you guys do that
yeah I do because I want to see what did
that person do that I didn't look
they're just better than you what do
they look like
yeah that's what you wanted oh that okay
yeah yeah do you have that that same
girl who always just beats you out of
everything yeah yeah every girl let's be
honest it's probably a Latina
that's like oh I only know of two that
yeah you [ __ ] stupid ass you said
every girl
well I mean every girl who goes out for
it for my part okay
so there's like a couple of girls that
you know firsthand that go oh there's
you know Cindy yeah and there are girls
who stay up on her Cindy Rodriguez who I
knew when I was working at a casting
office and this is before I thought that
there were a million other Latin girls
who looked just like me who are just as
qualified as me who are just as good as
me I used to think like yeah I'm kind of
special I'm like no you're not you're
absolutely not [ __ ] special no one
gives a [ __ ] about you and I was working
in this casting office and I would see
just hundreds of girls coming in like me
and this was like three years ago I was
working there and a bunch of the girls
who I used to help out there who would
come in like with the wrong sides I
would just like slip them the right
sides under the table I would help
then put their name later I'm like here
so I work on it yeah
and there was this one specific girl who
I helped out like that gave her a
highlighter I was like we're gonna have
you go I'm just gonna have you go less
so work on your [ __ ] and she wanted to
know feedback she called the office no
one got back to her so I took down her
number I called her told her the
feedback I mean she booked that was on
like five seasons she just booked this
movie she's killing it and she's like
mommy thank you so much like I remember
when you were there and it was like you
know like it's before I even started and
you were there already I mean I I loved
her but what could I just a reminder I'm
like yeah no I remember - I'm still not
there thank you because I want to say
this though is is that when when we were
auditioning girls for to play my
girlfriend unloved oh yeah they had me
with you know the casting director and
read with girls so for the first time I
could he I known knew what it was like
to be on the other end and they would
close the door and it wasn't personal
that's what I realized from it it's just
kind of like she just doesn't seem like
she would be my girlfriend she's great
actress that was a great choice yeah and
then you just move on from it yeah and
the girl that got it was like yeah she
looks kind of like kalila in many ways
she's half Filipino yeah and she has
she's in that same realm and then in and
then Alison agreed with issues like yeah
I think that right that fits I go yeah
she got it was she the best one I
wouldn't you know there was a lot of
good girls yeah you know but you know
it's a lot of times it's just chemistry
and just what your gut says or what its
gonna look like together or whatever so
it's like it's not a [ __ ] personal
thing and I just want to go back and
apologize to Cullen brothers I
feel I feel all right yeah you know it
was just you know what let's just be
honest all right all right
it is what it was you know it is what it
is what it was and you know I might have
not been the right guy for the thing we
were all in the situation and I have no
hard feelings at the end of the day you
know I had a the worst two weeks of my
life but I don't want to you know mean
burn bridges with them not that they
would ever hire me for anything but I
just yeah they still work anyone enough
yeah it is a different [ __ ] beast out
here
[Music]